s'effondre le rouble a baissé de 50%
depuis que poutine a annoncé sa guerre
un rouble vos mois d'un penny américain
un rouble
et la banque centrale russe tente de
protéger le rouble
est de plus en plus difficile nous avons
isolé les plus grandes banques russes du
système financier international et nous
avons réduit leur capacité à faire des
affaires avec le reste du monde nous
avons réduit leur accès à la haute
technologie comme des semi conducteurs
par exemple nous en travaux sa force
économique et cela a des complices cela
des conséquences militaire pour les
années à venir
ce week-end visa mastercard american
express ans que nous l'ayons demandés
ont suspendu leurs services en russie et
le rejoigne le grand nombre
d'entreprises américaines comme apple
par exemple qui ont suspendu leurs
opérations en russie
nous avons suspendu la formation de
services de sécurité russes
le département de la justice américain a
créé une équipe spéciale pour
poursuivre les infractions des commises
par les oligarques les jets privés ne
peuvent plus atterrir nous voulons que
tout le monde partagent le fardeau de la
guerre de poutine g en paie le prix
de ses fidèles décisions que nous
prenons aujourd'hui aura
un prix car poutine
menace
déjà des familles américaines a déjà des
conséquences négatives et avec ces
mesures les prix de l'énergie vont
augmenter nous allons faire tout ce que
nous pouvons pour en réduire les
conséquences il y à 16 millions de
barils
qui vont être tirés de nos réserves
nationales
et 3 millions de ces réserves viennent
des états unis nous prenons des mesures
pour faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
approvisionnement fiable pour l'énergie
mondiale
nous allons faire en sorte de protéger
de les familles et les entreprises
américaines
les entreprises du secteur pétrolier et
gazier
nous comprenons que la guerre de poutine
contre la population ukrainienne
provoque une augmentation des prix de
l'énergie mais mais mais ce n'est pas
une excuse pour faire augmenter les prix
de manière excessive
il ne faut pas exploiter la situation
au détriment des consommateurs
l'agression russe nous touche tous
négativement et il n'est pas temps ce
n'est pas le moment de profiter de la
situation c'est quelque chose que nous
ne tolèrerons pas je tiens également à
reconnaître cependant le fait que ces
entreprises du secteur se retire de la
de la russie serve d'exemple et nous
devons jouer notre rôle pour faire en
sorte que nous ne profitons pas de la
situation il faut être clair il y a deux
points d'abord
il n'est pas vrai que mon administration
il a gelé la production d'énergie même y
compris lors de la pandémie nous avons
mis à disposition plus d'énergie que
lors de la première année du mandat de
mon prédécesseur
nous allons sûrement atteindre un record
de production l'année prochaine 90% 11
de la production
pétrolière
sur terre et sur des terres fédérales
il y à
9000 gisement qui peuvent faire l'objet
de forages
sur terre sur le continent donc on a des
exploitations qui ont déjà été
approuvées donc il faut être clair le
fait qu'aujourd'hui ces gisements ne
sont pas utilisés pour la production il
faut être franc ensuite cette crise nous
rappelle qu'il faut protéger notre
économie à long terme il faut devenir
indépendant du point de vue énergétique
nous avons eu des discussions avec
nos partenaires il faut se libérer du
pétrole
russe
je sais ce que nous disions à nos alliés
européens
et à l'avenir nous espérons pouvoir être
davantage indépendants
et
les prix de l'énergie pour les familles
ne baisseront pas par le biais de la
réglementation mais il faut l'énergie
propre il faut des crédits d'impôt pour
les familles pour des énergies propres
ça ça nous permettra d'atteindre ses
objectifs
et si nous y parvenons cela veut dire
que personne ne devra se préoccuper des
prix à la pompe à l'avenir pour le gaz
poutine utilisent les hydrocarbures en
tant qu'arme et nous ne voulons faire en
sorte qu'il n'est plus cette possibilité
nous allons devenir un leader à
l'échelle mondiale voilà notre
l'objectif que nous devons nous fixer au
cours des deux dernières semaines le
peuple
ukrainien a inspiré le monde entier
avec leur patriotisme leur détermination
vous vis-à-vis de poutine et la guerre
de poutine a causé énormément de
souffrance énormément de pertes humaines
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants dans
tout le cren
les dirigeants ukrainiens les dirigeants
du monde entier ont appelé à de
nombreuses reprises un cessez le feu à
une aide humanitaire à une véritable
diplomatie mai poutine semble déterminé
à poursuivre sa trajectoire meurtrière
quel qu'en soit le coût des villes ont
été ciblés des civils des écoles des
hôpitaux
il a attaqué la semaine dernière la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe sans
se demander si cela pouvait conduire à
un accident nucléaire majeur
il y à des réfugiés ukrainien qui
tentent de quitter le pays et les russes
avancent et cela a un prix énorme mais
il faut être clair le fait que l'ukraine
ne sera jamais une victoire pour poutine
il peut prendre une ville mais ne pourra
jamais tenir le pays et si nous ne
répondons pas à l'attack de poutine
contre la paix la stabilité du monde et
bien il y aura davantage de souffrances
demain donc nous allons intensifier
notre soutien au peuple ukrainien et
j'appelle le congrès à adopter
un paquet adopté un paquet d'assistance
2,12 millions de dollars
poutine ne peut pas prendre ce qu'il
veut il faut défendre la liberté la
démocratie
et nous allons aider les et craignent un
à le faire nous allons fournir une
assistance économique et humanitaire
contre la tyrannie contre l'oppression
contre la violence la coercition
tout le monde aujourd'hui se lève pour
la liberté
et la guerre de poutine contre le cren
affaiblira la russie et renforcera le
reste du monde que dieu bénisse tous
ceux qui se trouvent en ukraine et
maintenant je dois vous quitter pour le
texas je vous remercie
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de questions
beaucoup d'interrogations mais il y a
beaucoup de choses à clarifier a précisé
je reviendrai vers vous lorsque nous
aurons davantage d'informations